la technique et a décidé de dépasser les
contes de fées et c'est au salon des
arts ménagers qu'on peut voir réaliser
les rêves les plus audacieux cette
cuisine de demain risque bien les filles
de sont rassurantes aspects de
laboratoires de donner le vertige à qui
la regarde de près et elle mérite certes
on la regarde de près
l'armoire à provisions réfrigérée et
rotative reçoit de l'extérieur les
livraisons des fournisseurs et vous la
porte au niveau souhaité les casseroles
arrive dès qu'on les appelle et cette
plaque de marbre d'italie restera d'une
merveilleuse fraîcheur mais il n'empêche
qu'elle mènera le lait à ébullition en
quelques secondes grâce à une
utilisation subtil du chauffage
induction grâce à une histoire
d'électroaimants ce dôme de verre
hémisphérique c'est tout bonnement un
four ou les rôtis sont grillés en
quelques instants à peine le temps de le
désirer
vous pourrez avoir la satisfaction de le
marchand de couleurs sous votre regard
la table serveuse à court d votre appel
et vous précède à nouveau dans la salle
à manger et les entremets sont juste
amener à la bonne température
aucune visite ne vous prendra au
dépourvu le bar à sa ration de boissons
glacées glaçons morceaux de glace
pulvérisé à votre choix encore que la
perspective de la vaisselle surtout ne
vous attriste pas les ultrasons
prendront pour vous cette corvée et même
les traces persistantes de rouge à
lèvres disparaîtront dans cette cuisine
laboratoire repose madame la
tranquillité que vous connaîtrez
peut-être
demain